si luis elle vivait dans son château la
reine elle avait son hameau il y a une
semaine versailles fêtaient la fin des
rénovations de la demeure de
marie-antoinette trois ans de travaux
pour reproduire au mieux l'atmosphère de
la maison de la reine ça imite un
village normand
mais en réalité vous avez des salon
salle à manger salle de billard de
boudoir un appartement entier pour la
reine une laiterie de préparation une
laiterie propreté bien évidemment les
bâtiments de service le réchauffement
quel nom donner à la cuisine c'est à
dire un vrai château
toutes les pièces et extérieur de la
maison ont été rénovés grâce aux
documentation historique le hameau de la
reine se situe dans un écrin de verdure
au pied d'un lac
c'est dans ce cadre bucolique qu'elle
souhaitait éduquer le successeur de
louis saez le hameau est à la fois un
lieu retiré de l'étiquette et du
protocole c'est aussi un lieu où elle
est elle même où elle dit qu'elle vit en
particulière où elle n'a pas
effectivement les contraintes de la cour
à travers les années la charpente s'est
dégradée napoléon a même transformer
l'édifice pour l'impératrice
marie-louise après la révolution
c'est l'architecte patrice bonnet qui
s'est en partie atteler aux rénovations
pour reproduire la maison de la reine de
l'époque ne vois pas faire une
restauration seulement conservatoire au
restauratrice il va exprimer que ce
hameau était à la fois un bâtiment de
marie antoinette et un bâtiment pour
l'impératrice marie-louise le hameau de
la reine ouvre ses portes au public à
partir du 12 mai comptait 22 euros pour
visiter les jardins et les appartements